also I do love that we're talking about
wet Hot American Summer because Paul
Rudd's anti-aging techniques whatever
they may be were on full display in the
sequel because that was filmed like what
15 years after the original and
everybody else aged and not great these
are comedians who drank and smoked and
did all right are you saying our
lifestyle was in the healthiest way they
play you know because they're playing
they don't they don't de-age them at all
they do no effort to make them look
younger they just have them playing
themselves at the same you know Summer
from Wet Hot American Summer and Michael
Showalter is hilarious yeah
all that you know became like a big guy
yeah yeah and he's just playing Coop the
same same way speaking of it just
because I I don't want to forget this
arguably my favorite character in the
entire movie is
the the host of the Talon Show that
we're going up to all day is a Michael
Showalter character and it's just this
old like Catskills comedus like what the
hell is this guy doing his personal
Inception yeah you're watching it and
every time I see it there's a little
tension of oh my God that's the Ghost of
Christmas future but it also reminded me
of Mr Saturday night which is a very
tough movie for Comics to watch and
where it's Billy Crystal Lake 90 still
doing like like jokes at a bowling alley
and you're like this poor guy just got a
gig but it's so funny and it was
heartwarming to see he's got another oh
hard he's killing in this little room
in nowhere but he's murdering yeah he's
got another one of those like little
tiny almost not even a joke jokes that's
so memorable when he called they do
they're doing day by day from Godspell
one of my favorite favorite Broadway
numbers day by day I don't know why I
can pronouncing it like that is so funny
oh I didn't get that I just thought it
was like like a day oh my gosh I didn't
even get it but if I can ask you and and
Jacqueline if you've seen it too because
uh given my lack of expertise on this
movie and what it's created since then I
was talking to producer Brian and he's
like no I think the the sequel was it
was a TV series
Netflix eight episode series spin-offs
series how do we feel about this there's
a prequel and a sequel yeah first day of
camp which goes to the the first day of
this Summer that we see we see the last
day of camp in wet Hot American Summer
yeah so the first Netflix show was a
prequel that shows them all arriving to
begin this that sound and it was filmed
when they were wailed so they're all
just they're all just old playing
themselves as high schoolers uh and then
the next one is 10 years later and we
see a full dramatization of them meeting
up again 10 years later to like talk
about their lives how do we feel about
these did they live up to it I think
they're great I mean it's it's not the
same experience because like we were
saying with the with the with the movie
it's like joke a minute it's not really
a story it's just coming at you these
they they try to make it more of like a
show and so it's more there's rise and
fall and plot lines or whatever so if
that sounds good to you it might sound
good to Jacqueline I was just about to
say
um the limitations yeah are are apparent
in some of them yes the limitations to
their storytelling did not like the
weakness that they were maybe papering
over in this first one was not something
they fortified as they made it linear it
was still in my opinion pretty flimsy
it's very it's the same sense of gleeful
absurdity yeah nothing has to really
link up nothing has to make logical
sense but they are fleshing it out more
and like putting a lot more and this one
it seems like it did and I will go go
back and watch these just again because
I enjoy the Creator so much they were
better received I mean that like there
were a lot of wet hot American it's over
fans already including among critics by
the time these came out so yeah there
was a more receptive ground people just
know if this is a thing for me I think
it's also fun to see we also see how
famous some of these people become and
so it's like oh my God I can't believe
right yeah they all they'll come back
and they did come back and then the Paul
wrote of it all he looked the same like
he legit like he's now I study him now
because first of all I study any white
person that Rivals black people's skin
because personally as somebody that
lives with somebody that it irritate
he's older than me he's older he's got
he's got good uh he's got he's got good
genes he's just it's it's infuriating I
feel like he's getting better I feel
like he and Tom Cruise are both like
they're right at this way where it is
starting it is just in the last team
like months like six months they're
actually beginning to look like human
people and it never used to happen no
like you would see Tom Cruise years
apart you'd be like still looks but this
one with that same bad wig take one take
two yeah it's like you don't even see a
difference and that ladies and gentlemen
is why you should go see quantumania
because he's finally become finally
becoming human he's finally coming to
the quantum realm but it's finally
wrinkle for your sanity I appreciate it
for you anyway that's kind of wrapping
imagine what being shrunk and then re
and then going huge and then coming back
I can't imagine what that does to your
skin I mean honestly I really hope he's
investing in moisturizer because he
should
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you